What's the most dangerous place on Earth?
Syria? Sudan?
No, the most dangerous place on Earth is right there: Cherna.
Cartels, militias, terrorist groups,...
..they all need a place to park their cash...
...and Cherna's their dirty little piggy bank.
We're going to insert into the country while nobody is looking,...
...locate the assets and secure them.
We're gonna steal their money, sir?
No, we are going to destroy it.
Everybody down now!
Jump or die!
Who the hell are you?
Our chopper was shot down.
The squad is dead.
You wanna trust a bunch of Blackwater mercs?
Anything we find on the ground is ours, understood?
Understood.
As long as we're stuck here, we're gonna finish this mission.
What's this mission of yours?
If we stay here, we're gonna die!
Then we die!